welcome to this interactive scrimba
course on html in this introduction i'm
going to explain the role of html on the
internet and why it is so important
what is html it is the standard markup
language for creating web pages and web
applications along with css and
javascript it is one of the cornerstones
of the world wide web every website and
every web application will render html
to the browser let me explain how the
web works in essence once you have
developed a website you need to host it
on a server to make it accessible to the
world wide web the server says here's my
number call me maybe that is what we
call an ip address and often we put a
domain name over that ip address so that
it is easy to remember
when you type that domain name on the
browser the browser will then give the
server a call and then the server will
send the hosted files back to the
browser to be rendered your browser will
first load the html which may reference
other css files and javascript files and
will load those references in the order
that they are listed in the html from
top to bottom so css and javascript is
built on top of html elements like skin
on bones
think of html as the skeleton html
provides tags to name different types of
content or rather elements on your
website for example the header element
the links
styles etc this helps your browser
understands what it reads to render it
properly even though the browser only
needs html to render a website think of
it as a skeleton with bare contents that
you will then make a dynamic and more
beautiful using javascript and css you
can think of javascript as the brains of
your website or web application it can
modify the html and css and re-render
elements of the page based on user input
or logic or changes in data from a
server this makes your html dynamic
rather than static
a dynamic website behaves more like this
after the page is rendered the user can
interact with inputs and elements on the
page and trigger javascript functions
which can modify the html elements and
contents the css and send or fetch data
to and from the server which then gets
sent back to the browser to be
re-rendered games and interactive
applications can be built upon html
thanks to javascript
however without rendered html elements
javascript and css will have no visible
usefulness on the browser you can think
of css like the skin of the website css
allows us to enhance the user experience
for visitors design a user interface
implement a brand identity apply
typographic and visual design principles
make the site responsive for mobile and
desktop viewing alike and overall a more
enjoyable experience
to look at and use now regardless of
whether you are looking to be a designer
of websites and web applications or a
more full stack developer of web
applications a thorough understanding of
html is a must and hopefully after this
course you will have html in your pocket
in this course i'll share with you the
boilerplate tags and explorations that
you'll need on every project we'll
practice element nesting and indentation
we'll learn how to use layout elements
semantically or properly learn how to
use metadata link scripts and style
elements we will use attributes ids
classes along the way we'll learn how to
embed images video and audio
we'll also practice using text
formatting elements we'll learn how to
make a numbered or bulleted list of
items and to wrap things up we'll learn
about forms and tables as a result we're
going to build a project using the most
useful elements and best practices of
html5 i will provide you with css and
javascript to make learning html more
visually enjoyable and fun my name is
eric you can find me as i am toronto
pretty much anywhere on social media if
you have any questions feel free to ask
me anytime or ask questions on the q a
section on the sidebar and let's jump
right in
for the browser to render a website it
needs html and for us to write html we
need an html document
and what makes an html document
that is having the extension of
html
over on the top left of our workspace we
have a gear icon by clicking there i can
select new file and i'm going to create
a new file and simply give it the name
of
hello.html to be added to my website
assets
as you can see
if we try to render this and open the
browser
we can see that we still have an error
when you enter a url on your browser
your browser makes a call to the server
requesting the website assets the screen
browser is automatically looking for the
assets in your project files here on our
files panel
but now it doesn't know what the name of
my html document is to render it
automatically if i tell the browser
exactly what document to look for it can
find it for example if i type
hello.html
hello world let's hit save again
and as we can see it will render hello
world but it could not find this on its
own
so how do we get a home page to load by
default all browsers will look for a
file called index.html in order to
render it as the home page also known as
the landing page for this reason every
project needs to contain an index.html
file the browser can load by default
now i'm going to go ahead and rename
this to index.html
i'm going to save it and now in the
browser here i'm going to type
index.html
and it will render hello world now the
browser will load this by default if you
would like to try this outside of
scrimba on your actual browser you may
use any text editor that comes with your
computer
and simply save a file and name it index
with the extension of dot html then drag
it onto your browser and it will render
whatever text you placed inside
there are more advanced and free text
editors out there that you can use to
edit html and other programming
languages such as atom
visual studio code and sublime text to
name a few
to create a javascript file you need to
use the extension of js and to create a
css file we need the extension of css
now these don't need any specific names
since our index.html document can tell
the browser the exact names of the
required css and javascripts we'll learn
more about that on another lesson but
for now let's name them index dot js and
index.css as well
index.js
index.css now that we have our html
document we can begin learning how to
code html see you in the next lesson
hello welcome to in this lesson we're
going to be practicing nesting and i've
prepared some css so that we can
visually understand nesting and how it
works and we're going to begin by
connecting that css style sheet to our
html document so let's go ahead and
begin there let's make a link
and you do that with the link tag
to create link and then we're going to
type rel which stands for relationship
and you're letting the browser know what
relationship this style sheet has to
html document that would be stylesheet
let's go ahead now and put the reference
to the
index.css okay so we have named this css
style sheet as index dot css it could be
named styles.css or anything else and
just make sure it has the same name okay
so now let's hit save and see what
happens
we have
a purple background color applied to the
body tag that's why everything turned
purple
let's remove this hello world here and
now we're going to play with nesting so
i'm going to create a div element this
is the most common element that is used
on html
and this element doesn't have any
semantic meaning it is pretty much for
any font that you want to divide from
other content that you're not sure if
you should use other semantic tags for
and as you can see i created this div
element with a opening tag and a closing
tag wrapped by the body opening tag and
the body closing tag so it's a child of
the body now let's add a class
by typing class equals
in quotation marks i'm going to put
white
and
now you're going to see that this
element has a white background it has a
width and a height this is because in
the css i have applied a style to any
element that has the class of white so
think of white or a class as a cell
phone number that the css can call and
then attribute styles to any element
that has
that class
and similarly there is an attribute
called id
but the id it is not meant to be used on
multiple elements only on one single
element on your whole document should
have that specific id so it's good for
when you're making an element there it's
going to be on your website only once
and you can call that
for example advertisement and then in
the css you can style that also
javascript uses ids and you communicate
with elements so we're going to leave
this as class of white okay i'm gonna
make another element here
and i'm gonna call it div
class
green
all right so now we have two elements
and as you can see they're not inside
each other they're next to each other
and that's because they are siblings now
what would happen if i grab this div
with the class of green
and put it inside the opening and
closing tags of the div with the class
of white i'm going to hit save
all right there we go now that green div
is visually also inside of the other
element it is wrapped by it
okay so i'm going to create a proper
indentation here so that we can visually
understand what's going on and now you
can pause this video go in here and
create another div inside of the green
div that has the class of red i'll wait
all right that should look something
like this
perfect i love it let's create more
elements
here if you like feel free to play
around however you want with this
these are the only three classes that i
have styled so
stick to those three classes there the
white green and red but you can have
multiple elements
and you can keep doing the same thing
for all of them pretty fun feel free to
play around with these elements and see
you in the next lesson
all right everybody let's go ahead and
populate uh this head element with some
meta tags well before the meta tags
let's do the title tag unfortunately we
cannot preview what the title tag does
on this browser because the the scrimba
browser doesn't show the title of the
page but just to illustrate it the title
of this lesson is called head elements
and
you can see that the title of this
course is also on the tab of your
browser and that is because your browser
is looking for the content of the title
tag and placing that on the tab on your
browser
so here we can say this html document is
called learning html and there are other
meta tags that you should add for
example the meta
char set
equals utf-8 so this is telling the
browser what character set you are using
to write your html document with okay
and there are other ones i'm going to
give it a name of description
and the content of that description is
going to be
my first html website
and as you can see there's no closing
tag for the meta tag and that is because
it is a self-closing tag it never
carries content so it doesn't require a
closing tag everything is in attributes
and values right inside the opening tag
itself there's one meta tag that you
must always have on a document
especially if you're going to be
building a responsive website and that
is called
the viewport meta tag so here we're
going to type name
viewport
and on the content we're going to
specify
the width
of the site is always the device
width
comma and let that initial scale
be
100
what this allows is for your browser to
render everything at a 100 scale
no matter what the width of your browser
is so you must always have this tag
especially if you're trying to build a
beautiful responsive website okay here
we have the link tag that we brought
over from our previous document it is
loaded in the same server as our html
but let me tell you that you can also
import an external style sheet from
anywhere on the web on our website we're
going to be using icons that come from a
style sheet
that is hosted on
fontawesome.com on awesome.com makes
fonts that we can access through html
classes i'm just going to import that
right in because we're going to be using
it on our project so this goes to show
that you can import a style sheet that's
loaded on your server or you can import
an external style sheet that it's on the
web now you can also have
you can also have embedded styles in the
document just know that whatever style
is here you cannot use it on another
page because you cannot import it or
reference it or link to it from another
html page let's write some content here
this is the header one element
which is the most important text on your
site you should only use it once per
page just so that the browser know what
the most important text is
here we're going to type
hello
world
and as you can see we have some text now
we're going to explore the header tags
later on but now i'm going to use this
style here to apply some text
to our hello world here so let's do
h1
and i'm going to do text
align
center
there you go i have aligned the text now
this dial right here will override this
index dot css because it is after in the
flow the browser will read this and then
overwrite it
with this now you will be able to
overwrite this if you do an inline style
and you do that by typing the
attribute of style
with the value of
let's say i'm going to do text align
left just to show you that i can
overwrite it
there you go in the line to the left it
overwrote what this specified right
there
now i'm going to do i'm going to change
the color to let's say
gold
there we go so i'm applying text align
center here
i'm applying color gold here
and this background purple comes from
the index dot css so that's two ways
that you can apply styles on your page
now there's another element that you can
use called script
so that you can run javascript right on
your website and i'm going to run a
simple script that says hello universe
and this is going to give an error let's
save it and that is because i don't have
anything with the id of h1 on the
document
so let's type
id
h1
hit save and we still have the error and
that is because we need to put script
after the element that we're trying to
modify with javascript hello universe
there you go i replace the content of
hello world with hello universe okay so
i'm not trying to give you a lesson on
javascript but even if you don't know
javascript you can import javascript
plugins that other people have developed
into your site so you always want to
make sure that it's inside the body
but it needs to be after the rest of the
content of your site
and now let's say
i want this to come from an external
javascript file so let's go ahead and
cut this out i'm going to put it inside
this javascript file
we lost the hello universe
and now for the script tag
i'm going to type source
index.js and i'm going to hit save
and there we go we've imported the same
javascript code that we had inside the
tag
from here
and now that we've got our head elements
set up our meta tags our styles and
script tags we're ready to start
building our layout let's go
in this lesson we're going to be
building this beautiful layout using the
layout elements that have been provided
to us using html5
let me tell you a little bit about how
we used to do it before we had these
layout elements we used to use the div
element to separate all kinds of
different content on our page
and to differentiate one div from
another we would use as classes
and you can do this today but html5 has
provided us tags for the most commonly
used layout elements so we're going to
replace this div
with
the header element
in here i'm just going to type header
and let's see what that looks like if
you ever want to see what these look
like without the styles just feel free
to comment out uh or remove this style
right here
and you'll see header right there okay
i'm going to put that back
another great layout element that we've
been given is the footer element
i don't know why i did two closing tags
there
see what that looks like perfect
all right
type footer in here
and another great element that they gave
us is the section element
now you may want to divide different
parts of your site by sections and you
don't have to use divs anymore
you can be a little bit more specific
and say this is a different section of
the page that's all it is pretty
straightforward
in here i'm going to type the main
elements
now this tells your browser what the
main content of this document is
so don't put anything that's repeated
throughout different pages in here don't
put the header in here don't put the
sidebar in here then put the footer in
here the main is for the specific
content of this document in here i'm
going to write the article element
and in here i'm going to type
article
let's see what that looks like
all right there we go i have an article
inside my main element i'm going to
multiply this
all right perfect
and now as a sibling of the main element
i'm going to place
the aside
what this says is this is content aside
of the main content so sometimes having
ads or a sidebar on our page can go
inside of the aside element one last one
that i'm going to use here i'm going to
replace this header type here for the
nav element
this is also very common elements and
they've given us an element for that and
i'm just going to
type here navigation and hit save
all right here we go we've built a basic
layout using the layout elements of
html5 on the next lesson we're going to
embed some images and a video
see you there
in this lesson we're gonna play around
with figure and image elements let's go
ahead and get started with the image
element
so here is the image tag
and the image tag does not have a
closing tag such as article it has a
closing tag here and the closing tag for
main it doesn't have that it is what we
call a self-closing element it does not
carry content inside of it uh
so you're just going to put forward
slash there at the end of the tag
and it has two attributes that are
required and one of those is source
and the other one
and the other one is alternate
and you type it as such
for the source attribute the value is
simply the name of your image or a link
to the image if the image were to be at
the root directory of your files such as
where this index.html is if it was at
the same level you would type simply the
name of the image and the extension
if the image is inside of a folder that
is at the root directory
of your project then you would type the
folder name
forward slash and then the image name
now i cannot upload an image here onto
scrimba but i can link to an external
image somewhere else on the internet so
i'm just going to grab a
url and paste it right here
i'm gonna hit save
there we go now we can see the image
uh feel free to play around with this uh
grab an image from the internet and try
to embed it
right there in the source this alternate
attribute
the value that you place here it
now for the
alt attribute
what you are telling the browser is if
you cannot load the image what alternate
information it can show so here you
simply type information about the image
such as
a laptop
with a mouse
on a desk
and
a pair of glasses
now this can be especially helpful for
people that are visiting your site but
are visually impaired and they may be
using screen readers to view
and maybe using screen readers to
navigate your site and
though they cannot see the image they
can get an idea of the image that you're
using
on your page as an illustration or a
graph
so these are the two required attributes
of the image tag
now let's go ahead and move on to the
figure
tag so this one does have an opening and
a closing tag so i'm going to go ahead
and put them in
i'm going to indent
image right here perfect now the figure
element has a an element uh
now the figure element has a child
element that is to be used together with
it and that is called fig caption
that also has
an opening and closing tag
and in here you're gonna i'm gonna write
a caption to the image just to give it a
little description
it could be an
now let's learn about the fig
now now let's learn about the figure
element
the figure element specifies
self-contained content not just images
it could be an illustration it could be
code photos diagrams etc
i'm going to write the closing tag here
and
what's special about the figure element
is that it has a child element that goes
along with it called fig caption and in
here you can write a caption that is
directly related to the content inside
the figure element
this could be at the top of the figure
element or the bottom as i am placing it
here and here i'm gonna describe
and here i'm going to describe
the
figure image
i'm going to hit save
all right and we can see how the browser
will attach this caption right to the
bottom of the image as a little
description
alternatively you can add styles to this
and change how it behaves
as an example i have made a class that
we can add here i have styled this with
css to the class of
hero i'm going to hit save there we go
we can see the caption is on top the
image is blurred uh you can play around
with figure and
editing the content of it so um
as you can see uh the css completely
modified the way the caption looks and
the image itself looks is now blurred so
don't feel limited by fig caption it is
another tool that we can use to style
our content
more effectively
so as you can see i have applied
so as you can see i have applied quite a
bit of
so as you can see i have modified quite
a bit uh the figure image
the figure element
so as you can see i have modified quite
a bit the figure element and the
contents of the figure elements such as
the image and the caption so don't feel
like it's going to limit you it is
simply more semantic to use it when you
need it and you are completely free to
make it look how you need it to and you
are completely free to make it look just
how you need it
hey guys in this lesson we're going to
learn how to embed a video using html
the first way is using the video element
i'm going to type video and i'm going to
treat it as a closing self-closing
element or a void element just like we
did with image meaning it has no closing
tag
in it i can type source
and for the source i can type the name
of the video
if it was in my root directory
it would be the name of the video if it
was inside a folder i would type the
folder name and then the video name
but because i don't have that i'm going
to go ahead and use an external video
source right here
now screamer cannot record the video
playing so i'm going to tell you to
pause the video here
open the preview and hit play for
yourself
were you able to
that is because there are no controls
you need to type the attribute of
controls so that you can hit play go
ahead jump into the code and now try to
play it
alright i hope you were able to
there are other attributes you can use
such as autoplay so the video plays by
itself there's one called muted so that
it is muted by default loop so the video
plays over and over again by itself
uh preload
so the video downloads or buffers before
the user hits play and there's also
width
uh i'm going to give it 600 pixels and
there's also height
can i give it a height of 350 pixels
alright
so there's my video but now i want my
video to be responsive if you can see
the frame of the video
the width does not change based on the
width of the viewports
so i have used css to create a class for
a wrapper so i'm going to wrap this in a
div with the class of
responsive
vid
and i'm going to hit save and now you'll
see that the boundaries of the video
should be responsive
now the video elements can take the
source as a nested element
for that i'm going to need to create a
closing tag for the video element and
the nested element is going to be called
source and in here i'm going to paste
the source attribute that i had before
now i'm going to use the type attribute
and i'm going to tell the browser this
is a video of the format mp4
now this is useful or necessary because
some browsers do not support formats
like ogd for example safari
and internet explorer so you need to
have a fallback source for those
browsers so this is good practice for
video make sure that you can upload
multiple formats of your video
especially if your website is going to
be used by people that may have older
browsers
another way that you can embed a video
is using the iframe elements
so i'm going to type the iframe opening
and closing tags
and the iframe can take a width actually
you need to give it a width so that you
can see the content and a height
as well so i'm going to give it 350
and these are pixel dimensions again and
for the source
to help you understand a little bit of
what the iframe does i'm just going to
type a url to the scrimba.com
page
so as you can see it has put the scrimba
page in a frame inside of my document if
this is not working in the recording go
ahead and jump into the preview yourself
and try to play with this but it has put
the scrimba website within my document
now this is the method that some
platforms will give you a video to be
embedded on your site such as youtube if
you find a video on youtube right below
there's going to be a tab that says
embed go ahead and click that and you
can copy
the code there which is
an iframe and paste it
those are the two ways in which you can
embed videos in html see you in the next
one
in this lesson we're going to learn
about list items and we're going to
build our navigation bar so to start off
i'm going to disable the css and also
this figure
element and in here i'm going to type
ul a ul element it has an opening and a
closing tag
that's because it's going to contain
certain elements and those elements are
li which stands for list item
and those have an opening and a closing
tag so ul stands for unordered list
i'm going to type here item 1 hit save
okay it's an unordered list meaning it
has no numbers
if you want one with numbers you do an
ordered list with an ol
there we go it has a number perfect
let's go back to ul
now list items behave as block elements
meaning they will stack vertically they
will not go in one line
but you can overwrite that with css
i'm gonna go ahead and put this style
sheet back and let's see what happened
to that ul
there we go we have it in a row
i'm gonna get rid of this text that i
don't need anymore
okay i'm gonna add some anchor tags
and i'm just going to put a pound symbol
there close the opening tag for the
anchor
and have another anchor
closing tag here
okay perfect so now these are links
inside of a list item
and that should add the default link
styles
perfect
i can have this outside of my header for
a different style that i've prepared so
these are different ways that you can
have an app you can have it a little
header or inside a header
as a matter of fact you could have it
as a sidebar or off canvas
if you notice that uh all of my content
is wrapped
by a div that has a class of center and
that is because i have styles for
sidebars i'm just going to go ahead and
type those up real quick
as well as a bar to toggle it triggering
some javascript
functions
let's take a look
isn't that neat
okay now i can also copy this unordered
list and put it on the sidebar for
example
and see what that looks like
awesome
beautiful
okay so there we go we have learned how
to use lists
remember if you want to see what this
stuff looks like without styles
just remove the css
take a look
all right there we go we learned about
list list items and how they can be used
we're going to keep building up our page
on the next lesson see you there
all right in this lesson we're learning
headings and headings are pretty easy
let's go ahead and get started i'm going
to scroll right below my figure elements
right here and i'm going to begin with
the most important heading of them all
and that is the h1
i'm going to type that here
and let's hit save and take a look
all right there we go this is the most
important heading
now i'm going to go to the least
important heading they go from one
through six so i'm gonna do h6
and i'm gonna type a little description
here
all right
the browser will render these at
different sizes h1 is the largest and h6
as the smallest
now we may be tempted to use h1 through
6 to style our text and make them larger
or smaller but the browser and search
engines and screen readers want to know
what the most important text of your
site is so use h1 through 6 to determine
importance not the size
so i want to say that learning html is
the most important
so i'm going to wrap it in the h1
and i'm going to use an h2 for this
header here
and i'm going to save it
and now we can see that it got smaller
but now let's say i want to make the h2
of a larger font size without changing
it to an h1 well that is why we have css
so i'm just going to go ahead and put
style here and font size and
i'm gonna make this
three ems and as we can see our h2 now
is visually larger but i'm still letting
the browser know it is not the most
important text of this document that's
pretty much it feel free to play with
headings h one through six and see you
in the next lesson
all right in this lesson we're learning
about paragraphs and some basic text
formatting in here it's a little bonus
we have the hr a horizontal row it
simply draws a line you can modify that
with css to look however you'd like but
uh let's begin with the paragraph tag so
that would be simply a p and we would
have an opening and a closing tag for
the p
and in here you can type anything you'd
like i have some text that talks about
html so i'm just going to paste that in
here let's hit save and see what that
looks like
all right there we go we got a paragraph
pretty boring so let's use some extra
markup here to jazz it up a little bit
so here we got hypertext markup language
i'm gonna make this bold and we're gonna
use the bold element which is simply a b
and we place the opening tag there and
i'm going to put the closing tag
over here after
html there we go
now that's bold
pretty cool
we got some other ones we got italics
i'm gonna turn cascading style sheets
and css into
italics so that is simply the i
and let's hit
save and let's take a look nice okay
cascading style sheets and css it's all
in italic
we also have another one called emphasis
which is em
as it save
and as you can see it also italicized it
but it is telling the browser that it is
not just italicized but it is more
important than other words because it is
emphasized so some of these tags don't
only change the style or the way that it
looks but also changes uh the meaning of
the words that are wrapped within them
we also have one called a strong
which is another word to add emphasis to
text and it is styled like bold
we also have another one that i think is
pretty neat it's called mark
it's pretty much like you grabbed a
marker or a highlighter
and went over the text let's take a look
at that there we go html documents is
highlighted i like that
and inside a paragraph you can also put
a link so let's say you want to put a
link in your text to another page on
your website or another page on the
internet
you can wrap your text in in an anchor
tag
type the href i'm just going to put a
pound symbol so it doesn't go anywhere
and put the closing tag
here
all right
html describes there you go it's a link
it doesn't do anything okay so this is
basic formatting for paragraphs i'm
going to show you a little bit more in
the next lesson
welcome to text formatting part two
now let's say that you want to break a
paragraph to start on a new line
you may have tried doing this right here
but uh that doesn't quite work and let
me tell you that there is a tag for that
and that would be the break tag let's
see how that looks
all right we see that web browsers is on
a new line after world wide web
perfect now i've seen people that will
pile these break tags like this to
create spaces between different lines of
text
that is not good practice just go ahead
and make a new paragraph like this
and there we go those are the two ways
in which you can break a new paragraph
to a new line another useful tag is the
block quote tag
if you have a quote on your document
and you want it to stand out
and i'm just going to paste the quote
that i found on the internet about
development and i'm going to hit save
let's take a look at that
all right beautiful
by default it is usually indented a
little bit from the left of where the
paragraphs are aligned
but i have styled it so that it looks
like this
the block quote tag can also take the
attribute of site
and you can put a citation to the source
of this quote i'm just going to say
twitter
and here we
go perfect
awesome
we also have a
tag of code
which is just letting the browser know
that you're putting code
inside of this element
and
i'm going to paste some css in here
just to
see what it looks like
all right and what it did is it put it
all in a single line but uh the browser
by default will apply what is called a
monospace typeface but what if we want
to keep our indentation for that we have
another tag called pre now this code
element doesn't really do much for me
i don't really need it i'm going to
replace it for the pre-tag
and let's see what that does
scroll down all right so three stands
for pre-formatting so all the
indentation that i gave my code stayed
there now i don't want all of this
indentation that i used to keep my code
pretty so unfortunately i'm gonna have
to
get rid of all this indentation
and let's take a look at it again right
perfect beautiful there we go and that
is how you use the code and the pre tag
and the block quotes i'm going to teach
you one more tag called the quote tag
and for that i'm just going to replace
this mark tag for a queue this is for a
short quote i'm going to save as you may
have noticed i did not add these
quotation marks but uh the browser will
add those quotation marks by defaults
all right i hope you had fun learning
these extra formatting elements and see
you in the next lesson
in this lesson we're going to cover the
basics of tables tables can be a bit
complicated for some people it was for
me at the beginning but i'm going to try
to make it as simple as possible let's
get started
when creating a table the first element
that we need to create is the table
element
and the table element can take a child
element of tr which stands for table row
and the table row element can take a
child
that is called the td or table data
element
and in here is where we would put our
content so i'm just going to type here
table
data
i'm going to duplicate this three times
let's take a look at that
and we have table data three times in a
single row
now i'm going to apply a class
so that it takes on a css style that
i've provided
and let's see what that looks like all
right here we go we got our table with
three table data elements in a single
row now i'm going to duplicate the table
row three times let's take a look at
that we have three rows and each row has
three td elements
now i'm going to duplicate this row one
more time i'm going to place it above
here
and there is another element that the
table row can nest and that is the th
which stands for
table header
i'm going to replace this with header
and let's see what that looks like
even though the browser applies some
styling by default
this styling right here comes from css
now the table header elements as well as
the table data element can take an
attribute
that is called
call
span
in other words span
this number of columns
so because i have three table data
elements creating three columns on each
row
and i want one of these to span across
all three columns all the way at the top
and i'm just going to call this
spanning three
columns
and let's take a look at that
all right here we go we got our table
header
spanning three columns
similar to that we have another
attribute called row span and i'm going
to apply it here
and now
this is going to make this able data
element span across a rows so if i
wanted to span through one two
three rows
i'm going to specify three and now let's
see what happens
huh
it spanned 3 rows but now it pushed 2
items out of the 3 columns and that is
because
that row span
has taken a spot
on this third row
as well as on this fourth row
so that is as if we had four columns
on the last two rows
and that is precisely what we're seeing
here on the last two rows we're seeing
one two three four columns and one two
three four columns
so we need to remove
table elements from those other two
columns for them to line up
in this lesson we're going to learn how
to use some of the more advanced
elements for tables
there are
three other elements
there are three other elements in tables
that allows you to group a certain
so we have group uh table data
under table rows
and
we have all of the table rows under our
table element now there are three other
elements that we can use to categorize
uh the rows that is t head
t body
and
t
foot
now i'm gonna go ahead and grab this row
and move it into
my head
and i'm going to move my content here to
the t body
so now it should look about the same but
what this allows me is to control all of
the elements that are inside the t head
separate from the elements that are in
the t body etc now i'm going to show you
another element that is called call
group it stands for column group and you
type it as such
call group opening and closing tag
the call group tag specifies a group of
one or more columns in a table
so that we can format it and it is
useful so that we can apply styles to
entire columns instead of repeating the
styles for each cell in each row
all right now we can nest an element
called co so that we can apply
a style to that whole column
and i'm going to choose
background
color let's do the blue
violet
color that we're using on our site and
let's see what that looks like
okay there we go
and the style that we applied has been
applied to every single cell
in that
column
now what would happen if
i copied this over
and let's change the color here
okay so now we have another column
now what if we switch them around in
order here
it will also switch around which column
has which color
and another attribute that we can place
here
is the span attribute and now i'm going
to tell it span
across two columns
and now we're gonna see that the yellow
spans across
two colors
again i'm gonna switch these around
and there we go now this is purple here
yellow here actually this should be up
right inside the entire table
and if i remove this style here we can
see that it affects all the rows
but because i have this style styling
the header it overwrites the default
style there of the call group
all right and now that we've learned
tables i'm going to have a little
challenge
in this challenge i want you to make a
section element inside of the footer
inside the section element i want you to
create a table with the class of styled
and inside that table i want you to
create three rows on the first row we're
going to have a table header cell with a
call span of two and you can write work
hours in there and for the last two rows
you're going to have a table data cell
with the following contents inside of it
we're going to be using these elements
in the next lesson you should be able to
do them either way i'll see you in the
next lesson
all right so now we're going to add some
final touches to make our sites look
more real make it come alive a little
bit
let's begin by changing our navigation
as you can see it says item one three
times that's not very realistic eric why
did you do that let's go ahead and
change these to top
i'm gonna do quotes
and i'm gonna do contact
us
i'm going to add a fourth one that is
called next
page
now the pound symbol in the reference
stands for an id so this is trying to
reference a blank id that does not exist
now how about we create links to actual
ids on our page on the main element here
i'm going to add the id
of
top
now i'm going to go looking for a block
quote
and add the id
of quote
and for the form
that we have on the bottom of our page
i'm going to add the id
of
contact
so now
now that we have these ids
i'm going to type them in the values for
each one of these links so
the id of top
the id of quote
the id of contact
and let's try these out so i'm going to
hit save
top okay i'm at the top already let's
hit quotes
it tried to place the contact form as
close as possible to the top
perfect now what about this next page
you may have noticed that i have a
document called next.htm
here on this page
i am simply going to reference the name
of the file which is next.html
and that is because it is at the same
level in the files directory as my
index.html now let's say there was a
folder here on the left that said pages
and the next.html document was inside
the pages folder i would have to put the
folder name here first and then the
document name but we can leave it like
this since next is at the root there
gonna hit save let's try that out
awesome
next.html we have linked to a separate
document in the same directory so you
can see it has different contents and
different colors because that document
has different ids and classes and i was
able to apply different styles awesome
let's go back to the homepage and let's
try the sidebar here
this
sidebar does not yet work so let's go
ahead and fix that so now i'm just going
to copy this ul
over to my
off canvas
sidebar
fix the indentation
let's try this out top quote contact us
back to top perfect next page
sweet
now we're done awesome i'm so glad you
made it this far you can pat yourself on
the back because now you know html
remember that if you have any questions
you can drop them in the q a section on
scrimba you can also interact with the
code and i hope that with your html
skills you can take them to the next
level take over the world and see you in
the next course